this is a production of Cornell
University
I'm going to talk today in a general way
about like these that covers the whole
field and the triceps summarizing 15
minutes basically what might be the
whole gist do and information about end
I want to start with a man named George
Leary who was one of the pioneer like
technologists of North America himself
published in 1847 the first manual of
likeness of the Northeast called the
light didn't book and set the type he
did the art he was a press he was a
newspaper editor in society and he
worked in also in factors where the
rodent wrote the dead one question is
but it was an extremely good early like
analogous and this is the beginning of
his book and because of the era
because of his training right to spout
of lyrical prose which and this this
passage encompasses sort of the whole
field very quickly the first paragraph
of this book like it's the humble plants
engaged like other mumble of this world
in mighty taxes their pardon is to cover
the Arctic and Alpine wastes to close
that close desert rocks and bare cliffs
everywhere as pioneers carrying life and
the means of exist
it's where the floor no life can exist
then so much themselves needing enough
soil looks foothold merely they create
so for plants which do need it with
powerful acids they etch the rock
loosening its particles Taleban frost
which will disintegrate it further most
surprising for centuries their minut
creeping diseases at last a chef
they give their there of my new
substance to the smaller and larger
things bacteria burns and koalas thus
they lay down the beginnings of one day
a fertile ground and this book is I
don't know six hundred some pages almost
everything is no strength this is the
first thing in North America and one of
the few places in the world where
someone claimed common names for
something as a spirits lichens it's a
very difficult of discipline to get into
and to teach yourself in terms of the
detail they struggled three years with
it by myself
and I'll talk about so that's me right
now we need to talk for a minute about
definition of lichens the International
Association for life enology in 1981
I've said that lichens were an
association that was promised and over
synthesizes
beyond these only unstable fallacy
specific structure so there are three
common components there the structure of
the posts in viata Michael the nil
capital and a biology textbook 1990 be
much more gently written lichens are
highly integrated symbiotic associations
of millions of algal cells table their
lattice point of life so in in the
meantime the last two years people have
discovered that there are also yeasts
associated with these so this is the
Luminess adversity Dissidia losing most
of like and enjoy your s :
the word life in its itself derives from
the Greek language sleep for a specific
300 BC kiss between bark outgrowths
Mohammed omelette trees and this is it
has a derivative in modern medicine
which is nice like in the cleanest and
also known as tumors a little bit of
history in the 1500s
a bee-like his run included a really
Protocol's including the one word
variable Holmen area which we'll see
later today it's a human to mingle item
it's like this today in the 1700s the
genus lichen was used by Turner for and
Linnaeus and a man named Macarius
founded the systematic study of lichens
the publication of his Methodist life
18:03 thus like inmates don't date
through the latest like most other
things in the taxonomic room like in
chemistry began to be studied by
Alexander Delta Nu Evans and Hale
University in the 1930s he was also an
ecologist also by the Japanese economic
experiment or physiological studies of
the lightness of neurosis begin in the
1950s and then ten years later would
begin to notice the effects of pollution
air pollution I'm likin biggering and
growth they're important organisms to
help monitor air quality the Enfield in
1932 and repeal in 1951 began to
integrate lichens and Bunga
classification systems and since 1971
Lucky's how many lichens Herman Bravo
who wrote a wonderful
it's like Lapierre really called nice
blankets of North America that's
beautifully illustrated colors focus
I'll show it to mama
if that was published in 2001 be
statement that divert about 14,000
likens working worldwide others have
suggested and of these 98 percent of our
asset have as a micro bite ask only
seeds an arrest receive a license we
have I think we have one that I've seen
winner to like then again I've showed me
show you some of these in fact this is
the law one of the local ones this is
the the clock like in multi clever
multikill a viola lucida and that was
founded the plain box preserve which is
one of the pre their reserves there were
no homes it's out there Brighton and the
primary tell us here is the green alga
and the Michael by interest wants the
variance apiece
no it's rhythmically space probably
something to do with nutritional
availability we covered a whole dead log
about a fallen bigtooth aspen tree that
had said what a wet area is the circus
monument so it was the fascinating to
make that statement to see it and he's
the first one
now it's it's interesting most most
groups of organisms are arranged by
taxonomy and we still do with likeness
but they're not really systematic but
rather an act logical or lifestyle
choice within the fungi that cross many
of the taxonomic units of fungi and
there you find out your biology rather
than their taxonomic identity a lot of
the ones in the upper triangular are
like an ice there's a little bit right
right there in the lick and they're
Rayleigh's that are not quite nice and
some of the others are
disproportionately so it's just so you
understand this concept and the use of
thin layer chromatography in recent
decades has helped between knowledge of
the species and the length of work I'd
like it's also now the scientific names
obviously you have to two organisms
living together so what do you do the
scientific names the genus and the
species of life and although referring
to the symbiotic association actually is
the name of the tunnel partner and the
Michael bite in the photosynthesizing
partner of the photo volume also has its
own taxonomic
even green algae and cyanobacteria
initially life is our unique remarkable
organisms derived from species belonging
to two or sometimes three but how the
kingdoms in I'm going to show you a
gallery images of them interview I hope
and appreciation of some of them the
colors and forms and so forth they're
very beautiful things and they're often
quite subtle but once your eyes are open
you start seeing memory they're slow
growing perennials met somebody very
very long life like for five thousand
years this is a concentric green lichen
which is as the interesting name marc
dopher Miglia centrifugal which is a
northern boreal and Arctic Lincoln that
grows on rocks and this this span is
about us putting our three feet across
and they grow very very slowly and you
see it has these concentric rings which
is that it's where the name comes this
is a cover of Audubon there showed some
beautiful colors of lightnings in the
background there's also a pointed so the
photo is just very quickly for books in
Italy which is a green alga this once
one is a common genus of green alga and
not stop using common cyanobacteria used
to be which are the major code of ions
of local legends and it's interesting
that the same species of or at least
genus of our green alga can be in
numerous general sponge life and
sometimes if you're looking in different
parts of the world of
once a in Central America from Europe in
the same way just a list here at the
general that have been compiled until I
think this book you can see there's a
large number of glorifying and green
algae this is the one I mentioned and
not stuck it's over there
this is a male bacteria but there are
other general now this is uh this is the
the actual association of the fungus and
have every now go where you have a
single cell aplasia uncle pothi so just
some awesome nomenclature will i have a
sheen i'm going to give you a sector
knew that lists a lot of the terminology
of course there's a specialized
terminology but this one isn't too hard
to learn salsa be honest a partner in
symbiosis microbiome you understand
fungal partner is alight and overbite
the one that photosynthesizes and then
if you want to get more more detailed of
cycle buying this the elbow partner in
this wagon of mine is a no bacterial
skin be on some models of the symbiosis
most lichens have surface and
particularly on polio slices that are
like leaves have an upper cortex in the
lower cortex and a middle area which is
filled with looser might be called women
fella and the album complement ranges
itself in a palisade under the
but inside and this is apparently to
shield it from too much direct Sun that
spreads it out and kills it and the
lightning also is the fungal part is
also holding water so that's this is the
simplest characterization wearing the
green I'll got one foe by a man one
Michael life here's one where you have a
little bummed about with fungal tissue
and then a different phone about there
probably say no bacteria I'll show you
some specimens of a local one that this
which is a flat cleaner when the girls
in the ground and then he sees wherever
as inclined in the drawing here wherever
you have the presence of the other photo
bian you have a different morphological
interaction with the fungus li you can
see where they are
this other one let's see I think is
another fungus and then you've got
another lichen on top they have waken
the coolest like instinct that are
associated with other lichens and this
is one of the three different foam
environment the common these are the
common and this sometimes I don't see
like a nucleus elections often but
they're very sluggishly there's
sometimes some things that people have
collected in in England into doing they
were interested in them two or three
decades ago we're catching on okay
structure of this ballast this is a life
like in their metal
learn them this is a wing that dry just
above the water and there it is wet and
speed water and grows on rocks right
next student up the water in streams and
when it's dry it has this this sort of
grayish brown bluish gray color when
it's green you see it looks much more
green that's because I guess because the
elves were happy they had water in there
they're able to-- since this is an
electron micrograph in a diagram of the
way years again where you have upper
cortex here see how dense it is and also
on the bottom and then the black dots
and br-2 green alga the Manoa sluice and
on the bottom I have my writings release
in Bullington straight on the bottom
this isn't police think it's in in
vertical segments which are struggling
and I'll talk again about about the most
different boring supply fancy second you
know this is a plutonium of the powdered
one like it
it has a primary that was in them as
these things that stick up out of it
called padishah in these kinds of things
you have a hollow interior and then so
you have an outer cortex some kinds and
then you have a degree now star is on
the edge but not outside so risings are
structures that hope the lichen firmly
on the substrate and they grow on rocks
they grow in rocks sometimes of this
porous lark and they're usually presto
so in there of that they have that
behavior they also grow on trees on dead
trees on the soil even even on things
like one like towards shelves so just
some of the forms this is across a bar
these are folios and these are floating
coaster shrubs life and a couple of
others
now this there are couple marks across
how certain quests like particles drug
like whether it's neat like obviously
squared their loss is a little less
stuff let's not be assistance plate here
shingle like I have some pictures up and
I'm bill okay it's really a subset of
folios with their they're often this big
some and they have a single point of
attachment maybe big strong kind of
structure that holds it on long
usually I'm vertical spaces look at me
okay so I'm gonna do a gallery now some
of these forms and things and some of
the species listen listen this is
christos it's not rock that's up stone
this unseen stone in the Catskills
East
miles where have the bright mint green
one is the maple dust like an ounce
which also grows on trees and these dust
like it is the great one in this this
stuff is fizzy odyssia which is another
gene so polios likens these are clusters
and also this this is the kind of
abstract painting you can see if you
have your eyes on community
now this one is fascinating because of
its very very focused micro habitat this
is called the sulphur dust like him also
on catskill sandstone and if you go to
cliffs particularly those that are
shaded run the north side stone walls
down the base where they don't get much
Sun and where it's moist
this beautiful sulphur yellow lichen
which is just powder how very kind of
texture to it
it doesn't have a cortex in other words
gross and you can see this on campus on
on the stone wall around the herb garden
this is here's another abstract even
desserts rolls around this this this one
that's flat on rock which is limestone
it's a Peters inflating Cynthia Peters
day I and the black diagonal in the
middle is and walks I think this machine
screw me but this is a rare thing
because it's rare that have outcropping
limestone as like they call it blank
stone pavement it's miles north and this
has got all these wonderful light
consider and other implants and
everything else in a butterfly sandstone
that are confined to that another's
crust dose grouper called cool likens in
the genus scalp Lac up there these two
species there at yellow one a bright red
orange one
these are at the theseö pretty much on
their top this is a fascinating local
one this easy to find it you know the
yellow perch it likes to grow in the
bark and it's got the the redundant lima
Gracchus scripta it's much like trailing
Arbutus in the well Clark's with
disability Ida reference which means
under anyway this one means it looks
like writing or pen and marks and these
are actually the marks are the empathy
see amenable partner and it has because
the occurs along slits with the si
excited
Elvis breakfast
okay this one has a hilarious
Dominique's
Peter Blagdon which is always on rotting
acid this is another micro micro focus
and a tad like the sulfur dust one the
same color actually this grows this is
sulfur stuff sulfur's bubble lightning
which is in the different room
it's an S but it doesn't and you
probably know what that means by now
it's got stuff swelling on the top where
the s-line are are disorganized their
mother anyway this one grows on soil on
the underside of north-facing
trees that have walked over in swamp so
they pull up this bit they pull up their
booths divers in the pool there if if
the exposed soil places in the work they
met the right exposure and the right one
and I can have a game with myself women
had the text like that to try to find it
and I usually can't I'm lucky but this
one is a fun thing fine this is
characteristic of some of the crust
particularly you know exactly the kind
of microbe that door maybe that's too
many
okay this is fabulous light as I've
mentioned this in Minnesota system
oyster like in these little plates are
the spaniels in this case they look like
oyster shells and it's also been called
the clam like you can see the scale
London will be here on the bottom this
is the like and I could study up for
several years and people these are on
usually on dead wood or living tree bark
that is PhD for think it's very acid a
substrate they growing on the campus
they used to growing on I think they
grow on late oak trees by
the arts blood and they establish huge
silver maple in front of chemistry bone
in addition in heaven on it's also on
planes in the Arboretum particularly
likes plants this one is a criticals
like it work it's living that category
at least this is about a centimeter tall
and it's well developed and maybe half
that tall around here is your sleepy
current topic this is the P this LP
berth lichen and this was on roadsides
in Maine where the low road sites were
like the same color because of foods
gross than this legged and has a primary
ballast on the bottom there suppress
coaster the bluish great-looking stuff
and then out of it from this little
mushroom like things but this is an ESCO
lichen and the puff top is the top of
the himemiya and the color when you see
a pole item like this at spots of color
it usually is if it's an ESCO I've seen
it usually is the parentheses that are
color around the outside it's
interesting this is a linoleum that is
it's just a little bunches of swam
Ewell's and you see how it's darker by
mind and this is another Vicryl
that thing this is usually in hobbies
most places and it will choose the place
where there's arranging this is
interesting just as another swing blows
it's also now this is a well-known man
this is British soldiers the don't
universe Pablo which is the main things
bad economy dates back to the
Revolutionary War in this country this
is on Deadwood but it's also unspoiled
it like it's a early successional thing
it's very rare to find this in this
natural state I found square yards of
them in the Albany Pine Bush and fire
missile a max of my embarrassment
situation where I think it was probably
and if I need to state something for
uranium or muffin on construction in
Sector two or three years this one is
another protocol I can form like
infidelity and see a list which looks
like a deer's horns
this is often on in Pine Barrens where
on other expose
situations on the ground this is the
cotton reindeer blight in which I've
seen around here on South Hill
unemployed bling this has the bluish
gray color of its distinctive from the
color and this is very strong white and
the I have examples of this rusty look
at this afternoon in there this group
Jesus Medina is interesting because each
note is like a conifer with this is
maybe the most beautiful this is
beautiful and this is Houston
it's Houston I found I have a bag of it
that I'll bring this afternoon that I
found in Michaels they use it in in arts
and crafts and everything soaked in
ingress listen they're very very
incredible so there's another kind of
writing
growing up it hangs down this is an
Adirondack boggans
on the right or Teresa dead that are
covered with white it's a nice and close
up here your spidey community you have
folio spikes here and then this is the
coarser one this 30 immense up needs a
morph up and they're smaller smaller
Bremen skull christening of which are a
number of others this is a I need a
situation wonderful advocates there to
see things as they are
one thing I noticed is that in
successional advocates like we've
created for twenty hundred years around
here like in felling that are that are
folios maybe about this big around three
or four inches across in the Adirondacks
when you find them in a situation like
that and you don't see that in the
younger ones they're always they always
say we're in the book so it's
interesting to see the difference now
this is a character that shows up once
in a while very nice we spend Halloween
with a costume
okay criticals lichens on trees this is
a nice light in from the west coast this
is from before balance Oregon it's all
the way along the West Coast didn't see
the lazy structure that was these are
absolutely magnificent to see I have a
friend in the sunlight contestant lapel
decorations were sweating this way
this is another cleaner particles like
this is on soil and rock and we held our
errands when Mike slinky it's also on
stand on legislation roads this is used
to be called Iceland once which is
excellence in Korea Icelanders but this
one is split out from that of Supriya
Erin area which means like insane very
very nice
so this is a weird thing but it has this
vertical shape is in the genus nest
usually moments they now full Neos mind
me mentioning there anything like and
there several of them gear that the two
that are important of the blue-gray more
than the greenish yellow one which are
very common and
identify their on this the trees along
how about for example maybe the smaller
ones in the middle are our this is
another genus and they're very good
colonizers they have little little
structures feltzer media that are about
twenty millimeter diameter of the
fireman
the other ones that see this is another
example of a large folio splendid son
this is living which is on records
across anyway this is the ago Parnelli
meaning yellow green color and you can
see the back piece here's the long work
and the valley of these are live
literally Mississippi they're just so
wonderful you can see them down in here
you can see the very the puckering and
reaching up the phallus if you turned it
over its model beige and brown and this
is something it's called long work
because it looks like lung tissue
and this name dates from the era of
herbals when people thought that
that looked like an organ could use to
help with diseases of that best pence
leaning this is the Jesus health teacher
this is an effort dog like Jessica I see
they are all on soil this usually had -
soil and this one see the color it's so
different and oh this is great color
indicates the same material and this is
a rock right now this is another Billick
eight one this is a cluster of them this
is a military man you wanna put this
stuff in the back of the things are our
crosses this this one the ballet our 8
meter 10 inches across sometimes smaller
- and they also are they reproduce by
Franklin so here's the close-up and as I
said they haven't it's the genus of
military family and going carry see and
the hidden abilities you see the repulse
here where the umbilicus is
their site the under site is why the top
is beautiful
it sort of grayish creature and
sometimes has other lichens growing
so that's one type one kind of bright
red this is a little smaller this one is
about the total skin lightening less
daily effective okay here's one here's
separate right in the lightest colored
spots for the umbilicus is and these are
beige and anything excellent
this one is another one in the same
genus in Celia as being a youngin
these are much bigger than they're
probably sometimes almost not now this
is a local one that is not a rock that
looks like when it has an inbuilt a porn
but rock types like acidic rocks and
they go we are most of the rocks around
here have one of these and this one this
is one that the cliff way further
medically not on which rose alignment
rods and they're usually the sizin
fingernails
these huge ones switches again in the
situation which is it's probably
undisturbed are maybe three inches
across this is done in Watkins Glen
there's a puckery service
surface with blue black dots and the
Ducks are the top of paramecia that are
buried in the in the mouth as opposed to
open enemies
now some vegetative reproduction
strategies the simplest way begin
diagrams here the simplest way is just a
piece break down like a swirl or a box
or something goes over like an steps on
and breaks a little bit there are two
micro micro swarms of fragmentation that
are are included in all keys in life in
books because they're so important
diagnostically one of them is I studio
which is shown in this one where you
have remember the layers here with the
vortices and Manila and then the motive
why I'm here
these finger-like projections are little
barrel length projections out of the
cortex and part of the Mandela would go
up into and then these bright buff and
making these lungs to know me
they're tiny but you can see we do your
bear is afternoon the other way this is
not as fun as this one in H where you
haven't seen the same structure but
instead of having something grow up in
the cortex and evidence a breakout of
things from the medulla it's low boats
man sub LT 23 slices are very tiny this
is something that our great city cortex
and then top and some things that are
going to educators so their cost
immediately we'll get to this later so
here's the antler like them and where
the red arrow is it you can see these in
here
there was tiny little pieces along the
branches and this one is this
remediating on their less obviously
recovery over here waiting there you can
see them in this one the red arrow this
is curled up wolves that are just
covering this
these are common in wet density and then
the oyster lichen that I talked about
before these are the scrambles and they
have they have a persistent surface of
this granule and then see all these
little Mountain cetera roving on the
bottom they are the media to still
remember with this whole structure is
about so here are that that's a actual
picture here's a cross section of an NPC
of width of a lightning race and all of
this stuff is glittery in green the edge
of this partner and then the fungal
partner provides the structure so just
ask Omar you might see sport diagrams to
show the variation of the fungi and that
group I like the
some reference that
I suppose that many of them are supports
entities and these are text limit
reference materials
now let's talk about like in habitats in
ecology they grow in all kinds of
habitats from HSN that see like we live
in sea water so it comes to the
windswept tops of mountains many kinds
of landscapes are softened artists this
is one characteristic of l-
Jeff really should a brilliant green
colour sari in pierrick this is but
these are old or very distinct this is
our new line you see now this is my
parents I've spent since no pigment as I
that you also see on cinematographers
just in song
same kind of situation very distinct
audiences in Jersey and in the Arctic on
the red side now this is a Pine Barrens
on the top of worksite outfox the shaman
students receive the legs here if you
get that they're rather sobering
peasants and they had this huge cat rock
on the Nero leagues that goes
flex you get different angles by
overthrowing much more you can see the
top of
the nation and the reason they're here I
think is because these chasms fill up
with Isis than you speak that sort of
deep snowball time fourth of July in
it's like this this is on scene
this is a similar kind of growth in
smoking the tax assistance
this great one is a critical one again
simple formula which is critical and the
greatness of
now this is an anomaly where you have
mics don't make McFerrin swings which
are of course it's only for rolling
around
fascinating now this is just some real
what we've been talking about this
ecology
birds are using weapons in this building
the one on the left is the northern
group of Warbler which is if it draws
together pieces of these enemies near
type of Langston which team is and then
the other is removing throated
hummingbird this is a female and she she
does all of the nest building and
rearing herself
so this is as you can see it's covered
with a but I'd like to be visible on
this day of pieces of plenty
this little how these birds sitting just
like circus move around she would have
to hover and take the villain like an
imperial officer about and then fly
penis fix it and she uses the nest is
built in Vietnam the smoke another nice
way to mix it mix it and then it's got
this music around yes I also like spear
but sometimes with the other so it's
just the whole thing's fascinating the
other person blue great men capture and
there's a gilded moths of liking moths
that feed on these these organisms to
notice the the monarch like a warning
coloring they probably like it's the two
components of platens produce unique
chemical compounds many of them are
assets these are useful to TLC
in taxonomy but they they also impart a
very nasty taste to the palace and so I
think that that properties is translated
into into the life cycle of the moth by
the larvae feeding and by the way the
larvae they don't bungle parson to see
the grease now this isn't like there you
can see the little trees there's the
life in this grave screen that looks
like those trees in business it's a Star
Trek I mean they're lucky
thanks to their sleep just similar to
the one in Florida this is the one that
person the Northeast it's a glorious and
excellent man on this was used
commercially in model railroads and
architectural models I remember when
I've only seen them and in modern times
we see more styrofoam they make very
nice little trucks and they're often
painted as I said I
it's accepted and even in this railroad
model the system oniy crostata with the
right now use other uses oak mosses the
genus of ernia are veiled and used for
striking domestic oil which holds
fragrances in attention Italian perfumes
and this is in Europe the same one
occurs in the West Coast in this country
this continent and we had one in
different
as far as I know it's not been used any
other other light continues and I still
you may be familiar in this paper in
high school biology or something like
that inches of acid-base indicator this
is made from a life of the line equation
we want this is a loom in Scotland where
their screen is being produced and this
is a woman very fine fabric that this
type of sometimes they grow so bigger
ously but they aren't welcome this is an
example another situation is that you
have ancient carvings the acid in ones
and it's
a long time they catch the classical
people's in Europe every thousand years
old so to get rid of it people do stuff
lunges sights and easier way problem is
just to cover it over until the life and
dies and then take a brush it's a modern
professional
okay the London indecency is no charity
here
like the two books I have these very
showings afternoon this is the lights in
North America Funko don't know sorry oh
this one is like roto and measurements
and the photographer to suggest it has
several hundreds of magnificent colors
photographs the other one is a very
funny it's the best like natok I've ever
seen in terms of its design
which also works in Christmas or post in
Latin
so we'll look at these later so this is
I guess I sank the beginning like
learning about like this is going bust
very difficult this is a beautiful
garden these are cooling so to speak and
this is energy
and so forth this idea of people who are
they can see these are loosely integers
consumer professional since but mostly
people who would highly because he
hasn't acknowledged level even get
together work like a stable wonderful
nice work
a lab like this can bring all their
microscopes and stuff it's a way to
learn and share with people you know how
to find all of us himself
it's a wonderful thing still going on
there that for you all over
Easton and all the way to Mississippi
thank you this has been a production of
Cornell University on the web at cornell
edu